a festive welcome to liverpool belying
the deadly serious nature of this
meeting g7 foreign ministers gathering
what a crisis is growing over russia and
ukraine
britain's foreign secretary liz truss
urging her counterparts to show unity
we need to defend ourselves against the
growing threats from hostile actors
and we need to come together
strongly to stand up to aggressors
who are seeking to limit
the bounds of freedom and democracy
aggressor number one is russia it's now
thought to have at least a hundred
thousand troops on or near its border
with ukraine
and inside ukraine russian-backed rebels
are preparing for deepening hostilities
while their patron in moscow keeps the
world guessing
vladimir putin may be a seasoned veteran
of real politik the foreign ministers of
the world's leading democracies aren't
five of the seven meeting here have been
in the job for less than a year
there's a lot at stake here can the g7
find the unity to deter russia from
aggression in ukraine but it's not just
russia this is a test for the west that
china and iran will also be watching
closely
but so far the g7 seems to be having
trouble finding its voice as they left
only the eu's foreign policy chief
talked to cameras claiming g7 unity on
russia
today has been the occasion for the big
democracy in the world to stand
together
behind ukraine
supporting its sovereignty and
territorial integrity
in front of any challenge any threat
that can come from russia if russia is
to listen the g7 will need their message
to be clearly heard
dominic waghorn sky news liverpool